what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and the absolute
mad lad tabata actually did it
black clover did the impossible
something that i said would be
absolutely incredible if it actually
happened but something that i didn't
think was really going to happen
it's just not how traditional shonen
series work
but this latest chapter of black clover
changed the whole game
up so let's talk about it if you enjoyed
the black lover content here on the
channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot
and if you are new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet do me a favor and
make
this the video do you subscribe and hit
that notification bell
to turn on all notifications before we
get into it
a quick thank you to summoner's war lost
centuria for sponsoring this video
summoner's war lost centuria is a brand
new mobile game that combines
real-time strategy and rpg mechanics in
unique and exciting ways
this new game comes from the same
universe as summoner's war
sky arena one of the most popular mobile
turn-based
rpgs which has over 110 million
downloads since this game is new now is
the best time to start playing to get a
leg
up on the competition they are
organizing a massive global launch event
which will feature crazy limited time
bonuses
and in-game events including summoner
academy
siege battle domination monster level up
and more
get crystals and free legend monsters
just for logging in
every day and form alliances with other
players to earn
even more awards together click the top
link
in the description to download the game
and take full advantage of these limited
time bonuses
right now i really enjoy the eight
versus eight real-time pvp battles with
fun counter-attack mechanics that keep
the fights fast-paced
and unpredictable check it out for
yourself just click
that link in the description to start
playing summoner's war
lost centuria right now finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
starts off with
luck voltea zooming through the palace
of the spade kingdom capital
and looking for the source of a familiar
magic power
luck must sense that at this very moment
magna and dante are duking it out
and as you will recall at the end of the
previous chapter
magna punched dante in the face and
actually knocked him down
and of course we were all wondering what
was going to happen
after that will magna really manage to
defeat
dante that was a highly unlikely
scenario
even with magna's new awesome spell so i
think that most of us took it for
granted that dante would of course get
back
up after being knocked down by magna and
this is exactly what happens at the
beginning
of this latest chapter dante manages to
get back up
and he is furious that a lowly peasant
like magna was able to knock him to the
ground
the fight then resumes with both dante
and magna exchanging blow after blow
in what is essentially an epic magical
boxing match
and i guess at one point dante did try
to use a sword but it didn't do much
good
dante then laughs and tells magna that
no matter how hard he tries
he will never be able to defeat him even
if they do have the exact same amount of
magic
dante's magic attributes are far
superior to magnus
and so no matter how much magna attacks
him he will just keep regenerating until
magna runs
out of steam dante believes that no
matter how much effort magna puts in
life is just not fair and a weak peasant
will never be able to compete with a
devil possessed
noble all of magnus hard work and
training will
always be in vain magna grits
his teeth he knows that he is just a
weak peasant
and that there is nothing special about
him he doesn't have royal blood
he wasn't born with an unusual amount of
magic unlike
luck he didn't unlock amazing new powers
after being possessed by an elf
and unlike osta he didn't find an
unconventional
op power like anti-magic in fact
back when he returned from the heart
kingdom magna straight up
asked yami why he even let him join the
black bulls
magna was genuinely wondering why
someone like him someone who doesn't
have a lot of magic power
or a lot of talent or an exceptional
magic attribute would even get a second
look from an overpowered magic knight
captain like yami
yami responds by saying that the two of
them share the same hobby
but more importantly yami says that
magna has
the biggest grit magna may not be the
strongest
or the most talented not even close but
he has an immense strength of
character he has the kind of courage and
resolve that the average person
simply does not have and that is why
yami knew that magna would be a great
fit
for the black bulls back on the
battlefield
magna vows that with his exceptional
grit he will never lose
and the fierce magical boxing match
continues with both men taking hit
after hit and yet fighting on and
fighting back
this goes on for quite a while and
eventually magna appears to have run
out of power he is slouched over and he
looks exhausted
and dante sees this as his chance and he
prepares to go
on the attack but then just as dante is
about to go
on another rant about how no matter how
hard magna struggles he will never be
able to defeat someone as powerful
as him dante suddenly reverts to his
base form
out of nowhere dante's devil power
vanishes completely
and he is just human again even dante
has no idea why this happened
and he demands an answer from magna what
did magna do to him
and how did he manage to sever the
connection between him
and lucifer magna just smiles and tells
dante that he didn't do anything
the two of them are just completely out
of magic power
after their long and exhausting boxing
match they've both
used up their magic however since dante
is used to having insane amounts of
magic
he has never experienced the feeling of
his magic being totally drained and
since dante never fought someone who had
an equal amount of magic
as he does he didn't realize just how
much power he was using up
during the fight this must be why the
connection between dante and lucifer was
severed
dante is used to having almost double
the magic that he currently has
and he is used to fighting opponents
with much less magic than him
so he accidentally pushed himself too
far and used up all of the magic power
in his possession and so now without any
magic power he cannot maintain his
connection to lucifer
and he can't use either of his magic
attributes
dante will have to continue this fight
without gravity magic
and without regeneration magic he will
have to fight magna with physical power
alone
as if both of them were just peasants
without any magic whatsoever
how ironic now of course magna is in the
same boat as dante he also used up all
of his magic power
but unlike dante magna is used to
fighting without overpowered magical
abilities
he is used to relying on physical
strength to make up for his lack of
magic
and so he knows how to fight using
physical power alone
as dante freaks out and screams that he
will never lose to a small fry like
magna
magna hits dante again and again punch
after punch and dante just can't keep up
magnus incredible physical resolve and
the raw physical power that he was
forced to develop in order to compensate
for his lack of exceptional magic or
talent
give him the crucial advantage in this
fight and he makes the best of it
just as luck asta and knocked show up to
see what's going on
they are shocked to see an exhausted but
ecstatic magna
standing over on unconscious dante
the chain created by secret flame magic
soul chain death match
dissolves signaling that magnus spell
has deactivated because his designated
opponent
dante has really been defeated magna
won magna actually defeated dante
the leader of the dark triad and the
human host of one of the absolutely
strongest devils
in the underworld this is amazing and i
can't believe tabata
actually went through with it i thought
that he would allow magna to give dante
a good fight give him some time to shine
but that he would ultimately be defeated
after buying some time for asta and the
others to arrive
but tabata actually committed to having
one of the strongest villains in the
entire series take the l
from a far weaker character 500 times
weaker
if we go by the numbers that were
provided in the previous chapter
whoa i am both surprised and impressed
by this turn of events
but what happens now clearly lucifer's
role in the story is far from
over he has been built up as one of the
strongest villains and liba has a
personal grudge against him
so this is clearly not the last we've
heard from him so
is lucifer about to just hijack dante's
body and use it for himself
without dante's consent or is he about
to possess the body of someone else
or is he gonna find a way to bring his
original body into this
world personally i think that dante has
pretty much
served his purpose as far as the story
goes
despite his overpowered magic he's now
lost twice
once to aston yami and wants to a
supposedly extremely weak peasant
i really can't see dante remaining
relevant as a character after this
lucifer will either take over his body
completely and push his consciousness
aside or he will just abandon dante and
find another host
or find a way to bring his own body into
this world the highest ranked devils
already looked down on humans
and after dante took this l from magna
there is no way that lucifer will still
have confidence in dante
as a host we are about to witness a
massive shift within the structure of
the dark
triad and the spade kingdom villains in
general
at least in my opinion but what did you
guys think about the shocking events
of this chapter did you really think
that magna could take dante down
and do you like the way in which tabata
made it happen he had a weaker character
dedicate six entire months to performing
one single spell
and it is a very specific spell with
strict restrictions
and limitations however once all of the
conditions were met and the spell was
activated magna was able to catch the
overly cocky dante
off guard dante simply did not have any
experience
fighting against an opponent who was
evenly matched with him and he certainly
didn't have experience fighting an
opponent who had the ability to cut his
own magical power in half
as a result dante was careless about how
he used his magic
and eventually he ran out of magic the
same thing happened to magna
but unlike dante magna had plenty of
experience
fighting without a lot of magic power at
his disposal
once both mages ran out of magic magna
had a decisive advantage
he had already trained his body to fight
using purely physical attacks because he
never had the luxury of relying on
powerful magic to solve
all of his problems meanwhile dante was
accustomed to winning fights by
overwhelming his opponents with superior
magic and he was also counting on his
ability to instantly regenerate
to protect him from any damage that he
might take but
when he could no longer use overwhelming
magic and when he could no longer
regenerate
it was just him versus magna in a battle
of physical strength and stamina
and that is a fight that dante simply
could not win
like i said i thought that this was a
really good way to change things up in
black clover and make the power system
more
interesting kudos to tabata i'm still in
shock about what happened
but i'm also excited to see where things
will go from here
if you guys enjoyed this black clover
video and you want more black lord
content here on the channel
please leave a like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar thanks again to this video
sponsor
summoner's war lost centuria check them
out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you